[Music]
okay for this one uh make sure to have
very strong opinions each step of the
way can't okay good there's a Dallas guy
his name's Johnny Abney okay this guy
got evicted from his apartment yay fake
name you like that no I always like
evictions especially when it's pushing
out people that are doing really
horrible in life and they need the house
but then it's let's let's make it even
worse by kicking them out you're you're
an advocate for tip your landlord aren't
you oh you know you know that initiative
you could tip your landlord what is that
no it's it's an ironic like initiative
where they're just like tip your
landlord they have a hard job it's like
a stupid no one's
doing so uh they threw out all of his
stuff this guy was living there with his
9-year-old daughter they threw all of
his [__] out into the back uh trash dump
area where people started picking
through it taking what they wanted
they uh broke stuff and then they even
peed on his
mattress and uh I know just extra cherry
on top are you sure it wasn't a dog
marking its territory it could have been
yeah why why did they throw out all this
stuff he was being evicted oh yeah he
wasn't paying [__] so uh what happened
is he basically lost all of his clothes
all of his possessions his mother's
ashes were in that pile also his
daughter's his daughter's trophies and
everything like just gone she won't
forget about the trophy she'll forget
was this like the sheriff's department
who's who's pulling him out of there uh
I'm not sure who made the call for that
but whoever did did an oopsie what did
they do wrong house no way wrong guy oh
my [__] god they evicted the wrong
tenant they meant to get a different oh
was it like an apartment with different
units oh and threw his [__] mom's ass
[__] that up dude I mean is suing okay
at this point yeah is that like a
multi-million dollar lawsuit so yeah so
he does end up uh filing for uh
compensation for everything that got
thrown out he wants the value and then
the the place is also like uh the
management is like yeah sorry that's on
us we will pay for everything that was
lost and damage emotional damage yeah
and emotional damage and things are
going fairly well
until they realize that he's not even
the legal tenant of his unit oh [__]
[__] so this guy was subleasing from his
ex who moved out of state and left the
place to him so that he could kind of
keep it at the same rate oh it's under
his yeah you know people do that they
just like you just pay the rent from now
on I'm leaving uh you yeah it's called
suing which means he's not entitled to a
penny which means the um the actual
company that runs the property they're
not even legally allowed to give him
money because he's not the actual tenant
well can they give her money can they
like what about rent does he have like
renters insurance or is that still under
the no cuz he's not even the legal you
can't yeah you can't notify the
authorities if you're doing something
illegal right it's like it's like if you
go rob a house and then someone beat you
up during the robber you can't call the
cops on the person that beat you up
while you're robbing the house is it
illegal this state you might be able
subing cuz you could subas maybe they
have a contract right yeah it might need
to be a much more formal thing but the
person that's actually leasing is the
person that would get the benefit of the
from the landlord they're suing so this
guy would have to technically like sue
his ex-girlfriend like those are that's
where the business relationship Li she
has to
sue goes like a triangle lawsuit
anything dud shouldn't have said
anything that's like that's like okay
I'm drunk driving right and then like
person next to me is not drinking do a
little switcher do a little switch
througho before the cop comes up to the
car right so this dude's got a lawyer
and the lawyer now is trying to fight
for him to get compensation by saying
that when they threw all that [__] out
they didn't know who it belonged to they
were just like throwing the [__] out so
you can't say like going that route yeah
because they're like if you knew that it
belonged to a person that wasn't legally
a renter then that would have been a
different situation sometimes I [__]
hate lawyers except when they save my
ass yeah isn't that the whole [__]
point lik any because lawyers they don't
look at like morality right they look at
how do I win this case so they're the
ultimate Loop holers so [__] like this
is like oh I know where we can get them
on they're busting a Shapiro God damn it
wait Did they what happened to the the
original people that were supposed to
get there did they get their [__] thrown
out the original they're still there
they're still they just got away like
Scott free they're just watching the
whole thing like what a disaster I think
they probably I think they probably just
peacefully left when they saw all that
[__] going down oh but uh yeah so the
lawyer saying you can't uh you threw it
out thinking it belonged to the actual
tenant in which you couldn't do that
anyway so now they're like trying to
fight for that but uh so the guy is
trying to they're trying to see if this
guy can actually become the real tenant
by just signing a lease like maybe you
can just sign a lease now and stay a
little late yeah a little late but then
uh the the building claims that they
won't give him a lease because when they
threw his [__] out they found
counterfeit money what does that have to
do with this is so [__] complicated
because it's a violation of like you
can't be having counterfeit or like uh
paraphernalia in it's like a breach of
your lease I guess yeah but that's
unlawful search and seizure meaning like
they they went and they wouldn't have
seen the evidence in the first place
they have c a lot well what about what
about the part where they were about to
like pay for everything and they
apologized had they already seen the
counterfeit money or is it because they
had well now they're starting to pull
out more like butts but like both sides
is like so so it's like their counter
they're countering the counter yeah so
so it's like first they threw him out
and the GU like that's not the right
[__] you guys are [__] oh I apologize
wait you're not the right person who
lives there it's like wait but you
didn't know who it was well you had
counterfeit money yes exactly it's like
it's like changing the Monopoly rules
mid game so uh so the news that is
covering this like the news channel
that's covering the story they went in
and they investigated the um the
possessions of that guy that were left
over to see if they could find any
counterfeit money and they did find some
play money that was clearly labeled like
not for use like it was something that
if it's film money then it's okay
obviously [__] gives a [__] yeah so
they're trying to use it looks like
they're trying to use that as the like
oh it's dude that's whack you can't have
fake money in your house clearly marked
as like money America dog yeah that's on
my check damn it's different in Dallas I
guess I guess that's [__] so that
dude basically since since this happened
he just like moved somewhere else it
just bounced but why they PE as the
Mom's ashes are still just laying on the
back I can't get past why they peed on
it stuff yeah is it just is it like a
[__] you cuz you you're you didn't pay
rent thing just a goose I think because
they threw it into the alley and it's
just all these people are just picking
at it and taking stuff and it's in a
place that's very PP friendly everything
into a dumpster yeah but it wouldn't all
fit it [__] just end because if you
throw stuff into a dumpster and it's all
like it's all like quality Goods people
are going to take it out of the dumpster
you know what I mean this guy's paying
his on time living life he was paying
rent for months was [__] working at
Subway and then you go home and your
house is trash and you're like someone
robbed me but you're like wait why would
a robber take
everything why would they mop the floor
yeah robber takes everything that's like
when [__] Fresh Prince got robbed why
would the robber take everything and
repaint it's like new carpet like it
smells like Pine saww and [__] like why
would they take it and clean
it new fixtures swap my blinds out these
are good blinds damn that sucks they
have made Home Improvements I know kit
it's a sad situation cuz he clearly like
wasn't really he wasn't doing anything
that different than what most people do
like everywhere this doesn't happen to
everyone you know what I mean but it
does show you that if you are subing
that you are subject to a lot of like
injustices that will happen to you
because those Agreements are like this
thick that's why yeah you have so much
fine print back there yeah so leing is a
risky take right yeah but don't you have
like a pack apartment sounds a little
sketch already you should have a pack
with your bud though who your suing with
it's like hey something happens you just
you you call and it's like we'll pretend
like it's it was all you but at the same
time people don't know the law you know
what's funny doesn't it make you wonder
if they truly did think they got the
wrong guy or if they knew he was in
there and they just wanted to throw him
out and say they got the wrong guy
because they knew that once his [__] was
out
he oh damn like they meant to do the
accident yeah yeah yeah yeah oh like
Oprah and
Maui like that I don't know dude that's
what you said no please dive deeper into
that on this parallel you created sites
are you on dude let's hear about it you
know Oprah is an American treasure she
would never do something Another Gay
won't be
at subing is not fun
though I think you opened up this world
I want hear it you mean the way that
Maui sues from
Oprah I don't think uh Texas has the
same rules as California where like it's
that hard to evict someone so then that
sounds like a California move to me
where you just break in move all the
[__] out you're like oh oops okay
technicality whereas like Texas is like
I don't know like two weeks you got the
whole [__] US Marshall breaking down
your door you're right you're right like
call would to do the loophole and Texas
probably doesn't need it as get the [__]
out just [__] rolling his
[Music]
revolver